are you a teacher
and a pervert
are you frustrated that you can't preach
transgenderism to five-year-olds well
have no fear
just move on up to new york city and
peddle all the creepy sex stuff you like
and we're partnering with with wpp
to put up billboards in major markets
across florida to let everyone know
we're targeting fort lauderdale
jacksonville orlando tampa and west palm
beach
we believe we're going to get about five
million impressions and they're going to
be up for an eight week period period
celebrating the diversity
and acceptance of new york city
we would show this in the billboards and
the billboards you have here right now
very clear statement and we're proud of
it other folks want people to hide their
color we like to show our color and
that's the rainbow that's representative
of this community
that's our color says the mayor of new
york now paying for billboards in
florida to to lure people up who are
opposed to the parental rights and
education bill he says come on up to
florida come on up to new york rather
leave florida take that desantis you
want to ban teachers from talking about
sex with first graders
well new york is going to swoop in and
take those perverts out of your state
how do you like that oh you do like that
you like that very much well that's a
win-win i guess except for
new yorkers whose taxpayer dollars are
now being spent trying to lure child
predators to their state
we're not talking about gay this is not
about don't say gay we're not talking
about your average
gay guys people who want to keep their
sex lives to themselves especially when
they're around kids no we're talking
about perverts who insist on talking
about genitals with kindergarteners
florida voted to protect kids
new york voted for people who want to
protect predators and now new yorkers
are going to have to deal even more
acutely with the consequences of
democracy the system of government
predicated on the idea that the common
people know what they want and deserve
to get it good and hard i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from eric weininger
who says i was hoping that as thursday's
top commenter i'd get prime seating
rights at your washburn speech i showed
up an hour early and had no chance of
getting in due to the great turnout come
back soon thank you very much i
appreciate that the speech was a lot of
fun at washburn the only regret i have
is that we only got a room that fit it
was 300 and then we stretched it made it
about 350. we turned away 200 people
we're going to get bigger rooms from now
on so very sorry we've got some other
speeches coming up i'm going to be at
grove city college coming up this week
on thursday then senator cruz and i are
going to yale and we're going to alabama
that'll be a lot of fun we've got some
more schools after that so be sure to uh
sign up for those you can do that at
young america's foundation yaf.org
and you know you're going to want to uh
get your energy up because sometimes you
know you get there early you wait in
line you want to make sure that you got
your blood flowing you're nice and full
when you want to get your energy up i
strongly recommend you have a nice big
meal of good ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com
the price of beef is skyrocketing it's
only going to get worse
over the summer right now you can lock
in your price for beef with good
ranchers once you subscribe your price
never goes up making good ranchers the
best way to inflation proof your meals
eighty-five percent of the grass-fed
beef you get in stores and online
it's imported from overseas even when it
says product of usa usually that is bs
usually it's just minimally processed
here but it's cheap cheap beef from
overseas
you can shop good ranchers for all your
beef chicken and seafood needs they only
sell 100 american meat from local farms
and ranches i eat good ranchers at this
point probably two to three times a week
i love it so much when i was a kid steak
was a really rare kind of special
occasion experience well good ranchers
the price is so low and you can lock in
right now to make an inflation proof you
can you can make steak a regular part of
your family's dining experience right
now get your 30 discount on prime steaks
and better than organic chicken today go
to goodranchers.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s good ranchers takes
the guesswork out of the grocery store
sends you top quality 100 american meat
to your door use code knowles k-w-l-e-s
get thirty dollars in savings
goodranchers.com
knowles
new york wants these people that florida
wants to kick out that's a win-win i
guess everybody's happy about that but
some of these
perverts who want to talk to
eight-year-olds seven-year-olds
six-year-olds five-year-olds
four-year-olds and three-year-olds about
sex without their parents consent
some of these people are refusing to
leave florida they are refusing to
follow the law they are going to
indoctrinate your kids in whatever weird
sex hang-ups they have whether you like
it or not
so because i've been getting this
question a lot lately i am going to use
this space to answer it
and that is as a preschool teacher a
drag king and as a member of the lgbtq
community
how
do i feel about the nude legislations
for like the don't say gay bill or
the reporting of transgender kids
and while i don't see things like that
too much in
preschool my opinion on it is
that i don't care what the government
tells me to do
i am going to do what i think is best
for the health
and safety
and that includes mental health and
safety and emotional health and safety
of my kids i will never let any child
come through my classroom feeling
unloved or ashamed for who they are
a
a drag king
who
is
becoming emotional to the verge of tears
because governor desantis and the voters
of florida don't want her to talk about
sex with preschoolers is lecturing the
rest of us on mental health
isn't that an amazing thing
slight side note i did not know drag
kings existed
somehow this is even weirder to me than
drag queens drag queens have existed
throughout all of history men who put on
dresses and put on shows they're sort of
funny right they're certainly very
eccentric drag king seems a little
weirder because that's just a woman
who's dressing up like a man which is
something that the feminists have been
doing since at least the 70s even
stranger somehow than some phenomenon
like drag queen story hour the point
though is is
lawlessness the point is we do not
believe
we the radical
leftist sexual revolutionary community
we do not believe
that ron desantis has any right to sign
this law that the voters of florida have
any right to elect representatives who
are going to pass this law and that
parents have any right to determine what
kind of creepy sex stuff their kids are
being taught in the classroom
and we're going to do it anyway i'm so
glad that this lady made this video lock
her up lock her up if she does this
which she's promising to do
one she shouldn't be teaching anyone
anyway she is a disturbed individual she
needs to go get help she should be kept
a hundred yards away from any children
but
beyond that assuming that she's still
going to remain in the classroom for now
arrest her she's violating the law
reminds me of of ronald reagan ronald
reagan on a completely separate issue
he he was faced with an air traffic
controller strike and the air traffic
controllers were public union and they
had no right to strike it was illegal
for them to strike they struck because
they didn't think the law was going to
be enforced and the law only has the the
force of its credibility of the
credibility of the people who are are
actually executing the laws so the air
traffic controllers thought they're
never going to fire us they're never
going to actually enforce this and
reagan walks up to the microphone and he
says
well if the air traffic controllers
don't get back in 48 hours they'll be
terminated and and he was asked a
question by the reporters he said don't
you think some lesser action is is more
appropriate here
he said what lesser action can there be
they're in violation of the law well
nancy that's it and and he did and he
actually made good on that threat and
that was a win for the rule of law and
that was a win for our republican form
of government and that was a win
for we the people for us the people who
who who form our government at least in
theory so it's it's very important if
this florida law
that is going to prevent pervs from
indoctrinating little tiny kids and sex
and gives parents some right in their
kids education if that's going to have
any teeth
it has to be enforced
people need to be made an example of
and i can think of no better example
than this lady who
it's not as though she's some
sympathetic figure who's upset because
she was talking about a nuanced and
academic issue with some older student a
17 year old and 18 year old she's
talking about
queer stuff
specifically queer stuff capital q
trademark over the r with preschoolers
make an example of her don't just fire
her prosecutor for violating this law
speaking of crimes
speaking of crimes on children
the most horrifying news story i have
ever seen in my entire life
just popped up on live action
and very few if any establishment media
sources are talking about it because
it's a politically inconvenient crime i
have lived through
many wars all around the world have
taken place in my lifetime all sorts of
terrible crimes murders and and
serial killings and all sorts of things
this is by far
by far the most horrifying crime
uh there
there have been discovered the frozen
remains of five aborted babies in
washington dc
and the part of the story that gets a
little weird is they were found in the
apartment of an anti-abortion activist
now it's not really weird when you
figure out what's going on here a
whistleblower at an abortion clinic
tipped off this anti-abortion activist
they have the evidence of these
abortions which are potentially illegal
abortions in that the babies may have
been born or partially born before they
were killed which would be in violation
of federal law but even if it's not
technically in violation of the civil
law
it's obviously it's a crime against
humanity it's a crime that cries out to
god because these are
these are babies these are so undeniably
babies who were who are in in
expressions of extreme pain who are
totally recognizable like any newborn
baby and they were killed through
abortion frankly if it's not in
violation of federal law that's an even
greater indictment of us
uh there are photos of this there's
evidence i have blurred the photos for
this show because because you'll have
nightmares
i would say if you are already pro-life
and you already oppose legal abortion
don't look up these pictures
don't look them up because you'll have
nightmares and there's no reason to you
already see the issue for what it is
if you are pro-choice
if you support legal abortion to any
degree
look up the pictures
click you can find them they're just
google live action abortion washington
dc
you'll see they're kind of blurred out
here
look them up if you if you support
abortion
and you think well it's a complicated
issue i don't like abortion personally
but it should be legal what to whatever
degree you support abortion click the
photos and tell me you support abortion
i don't think anyone but an absolute
stone cold sociopath can look at these
photos and tell me that they still
support
abortion that's why it's so important
the work that live action has done here
it's so important that the work that
this anti-abortion activist has done
here and the response of the government
tells you everything you need to know
about this evil institution and the
extremely corrupt people who are
covering up for it
this anti-abortion activist
lauren handy i believe her name is
has been indicted so she was the one
she's the anti-abortion activist the
pro-life activist who was discovered to
have these frozen
bodies in her home
that she was apparently given by a
whistleblower
she has been indicted along with eight
others on federal felony conspiracy
charges
what are the charges she's accused
of blocking access to a dc abortion
clinic in october of 2020.
this blockade
was broadcast on facebook
and now she's up on federal charges
i'm sure she will now have new charges
added to the list
because of her storage of these bodies
do you know who's not going to have any
charges brought against them do you know
who's not going to be held in any way
responsible for these crimes that cry
out to god these the the
the
absolute slaughter of children who have
pained expressions on their face frozen
from this moment joe's not gonna have
any consequences the people who did it
that's that's who th the person who blew
the whistle on it the people who expose
these crimes to the world they're
probably gonna to center behind bars for
a long time the people who committed
these crimes outright infanticide
nothing is going to happen to them at
all take a listen to the executive
assistant chief of police in washington
dc
ms handy is been indicted on a federal
investigation led by the fbi that mpd
was not a part of
so that's number one the second piece is
that we were led to that house that you
mentioned
we did recover items that were
these are preliminary results ocme
looked took a look at those items they
are have been confirmed as fetuses
um
what we're seeing now is they those
fetuses were aborted in accordance with
dc law so we are not investigating
this incident along those lines does
this be anything criminal in nature
right now about that
except for how they got into this house
and so we're continuing to look at that
they were aborted oh no i'm sorry let me
rewind
these items that were found
were fetuses the i so the people the
little babies who were killed they're
they're items they're just objects
and turns out the objects are fetuses
which is the
the latin word for baby but we have to
use the word fetus so that we can
dehumanize the babies
and the and the babies
were killed they were
killed with these pained expressions on
their faces in accordance with dc law so
there's no crime there nothing's being
investigated
the only crime is how they got to the
house
according to
our authorities i love
america i believe in america to quote
the first line of the godfather
very hard it's very hard to love america
when you hear that kind of stuff it's
very hard
when you think about all the awful
regimes in the world
there are lots of terrible regimes we
we never stop or our ruling class never
stops talking about all the evil regimes
around the world
and then you listen to one of our public
authorities say that the five babies
that we are looking at we can look them
right in their eyes and their cold eyes
we can look at what happened to them and
say there was no crime here
totally in accordance with the law
the only crime
was that this was exposed
if the babies are just items that were
discovered in a home
what's the big deal they're just i have
items in my home you probably have items
in your home don't you we all have items
items not a big deal
it's a big deal and they're
investigating the woman who had had the
bodies in their homes because their
bodies because they're human beings who
were who whose dead bodies were being
treated in this unusual way
that's why it's a big deal but
the the criminals the killers who killed
the babies they're not being prosecuted
or even investigated because they're not
bodies they're just they're just items
they're trying to have both sides of
this and they're trying to have both
sides to
to attack the good guys to persecute the
good guys who are exposing the crime and
to cover up for the killers
it's very hard i still love my country i
still love america but it's really hard
to do that
when you consider that america kills
upwards of a million babies a year and
speaks of it in such callous terms and
when you see the reality of it when you
can look the babies right in the eye
and these psychos who run our country
say no crime here
they want they won't perform an autopsy
they can't perform an autopsy because to
perform an autopsy would be to admit
that these are babies
they're not going to perform an autopsy
because by the way
what what the assistant police chief
just said here
very likely isn't true the babies may
very well have been killed in violation
of federal law partial birth abortions
are a violation of federal law and
there's a lot of evidence that that's
how they were killed
but nope cover up nothing to see here
move along move along move along
sick sick and it's spreading there's a
law that was just passed in colorado
legalizes
legalizes abortion through all nine
months of pregnancy you can be 30
seconds away from birth
in the process of giving birth you can
choose to kill your baby in colorado so
says colorado governor jared polis
this uh this law defines abortion as a
right and it goes even further than just
permitting abortion up until the moment
of birth
this law in colorado may very well force
medical professionals to to
be involved in abortions against their
will there's no religious exemption
there's no moral exemption to this
if you are
a christian
jew muslim if you're if you're just a
regular
ordinary agnostic person with a
conscience
according to this law you very likely
can't even opt out of performing an
abortion
zero conscience protections at all
sick stuff
i think this is one of the reasons
that
when we talk about regimes overseas when
we talk about all the awful tin pot
dictators all around the world when when
some of our ruling class tries to get
people riled up for more regime change
wars the kind of regime change wars we
saw under george w bush we saw under
barack obama i think part of the reason
that we we can't get excited about that
anymore is because our own ruling class
is so hideously corrupt so hideously
psychopathically when you talk about
stuff like this evil so evil
that it's it's hard for us to summon the
moral indignation that wasn't always
true in america we used to feel that we
had the moral high ground and we
relatively did have the moral high
ground around the world and we don't
know and if we want to gain that back if
we want to have any kind of beyond even
the issue of abortion
you want to get your national mojo back
then stop doing the most evil things you
can possibly do and stop enshrining it
in law
and just call it for what it is we
there are a lot of squishes who want us
to just
cool down the rhetoric okay we've no
this is just evil stuff these people are
the spawn of satan these are children of
hell who are running colorado right now
who are running washington dc and they
ought to be utterly removed from power
and they should spend the rest of their
lives in jail they should be prosecuted
for what they're doing certainly the
killers should be prosecuted in this
case and they won't they're going to be
the most protected people on earth it's
disgusting it's absolutely disgusting
no wonder no wonder americans think the
country is going in the wrong direction
does it have to do with gas prices yes
it actually does it has a lot to do with
get does it have to do with inflation
yes it does does it have to do with the
embarrassment that americans feel
because our president is incompetent and
his brain is made of pudding yes but it
also has to do with the genuinely evil
stuff that is going on in this country
and that is getting worse
in this country it has something to do
with that too okay you can't you can't
live in a country
where
you have lots of evil things going on
and lots of evil things getting worse
and a ruling class that is openly
encouraging it and have that country
feel really good about itself it's just
not possible no matter how many lies you
tell no matter how many politically
correct euphemisms you use no matter how
many times you insist no it's a clump of
cells look at the pictures tell me
that's a clump of cells look at the
pictures if you're going to use that
phrase
you can't do it you can't reality
reasserts itself in the end okay and you
can't
we've talked about this
on another issue on transgenderism we've
talked about this on so many aspects of
the left's political agenda you can't
live in fantasy forever okay reality is
going to come come nagging back at you
come poking back at you and you're not
going to be able to suppress your
conscience forever
there is some good news there is some
good news
in politics it's not all doom and gloom
it's not all bad hope springs eternal in
the human breast and there is on a
completely separate issue
some really great news one of the the
biggest challenges in america today is
that we are a
republic at least we're supposed to be
i mean self-government that means that
we govern ourselves by persuading one
another by debating by speaking to one
another and and we do that in the public
square now we no longer really have
physical public squares
we have digital public squares because
we live in the internet age so that
means
that when big tech platforms which
control the entire flow of internet
entire flow of information around the
internet when they shut people out when
they censor certain topics when they
censor certain points of view when they
ban for instance the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
that
is is a major threat to our democracy
to our republic to the whole form of
government
well
someone is doing something about that
right now elon musk
one of the most delightfully eccentric
billionaires in the world
has had enough he sent out a twitter
poll the other day he said free speech
is essential to a functioning democracy
do you believe twitter rigorously
adheres to this principle yes or no and
he said be careful how you answer
the consequences of this poll will be
important please vote carefully so the
majority of people believed that twitter
is not protecting free speech they
believe that free speech is very
important to democracy and so elon musk
has bought 9.2 percent of twitter he is
now the largest
stakeholder in twitter
and he intends to turn that company
around
i'm very excited to announce today the
release of andrew clavin's latest book
the truth and beauty after years
studying the gospels and trying to find
the true meaning of jesus's words drew
is ready to share what he has found it's
for anyone who's seeking to find renewed
meaning in their faith or maybe striving
for belief in a materialistic world i
really love this book i read it months
ago i got an advanced copy from drew and
i but i'd been bugging him to read this
book ever since he told me about it
it's such a weird book it's part memoir
it's it's part
of theological meditation
and it's part
of writing about the romantic poets this
group of english poets from centuries
ago and it's and it's written in that
classic drew way which is just so
straightforward completely unpretentious
you've got some of the most profound
ideas that could be understood by a
third grader c.s lewis has this gift too
and drew certainly has it so head on
over to amazon wherever you buy books
order your copy of the truth and beauty
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
elon musk now owns 9.2 percent of
twitter
to put that in perspective
jack dorsey the founder and former ceo
of twitter owns 2.25
so so
elon musk owns almost four times
the the amount of twitter that jack
dorsey owns
as a result of this purchase twitter
shares surged
26 in pre-market trading uh the the
stake that elon has is about 2.89
billion dollars
and what does this actually mean does
this mean that elon musk is going to
make a lot of money on twitter i don't
know maybe it will maybe it won't he's a
smart investor so i suppose he'll
probably make money but i suspect this
isn't primarily about money this is
about elon musk going in and throwing
his weight around and saying we are not
going to let free speech die in america
this is so beautiful and the context
here why is this happening right now the
the twitter annual meeting is may 25th
so when you own
when you own over nine percent of a
company like twitter
you can force the company to do certain
things half of me wonders if the reason
that elon musk bought all this twitter
stock is is just to get the babylon bees
account back
because the babylon b which elon has
appeared on before made some joke about
transgenderism and they were banned and
they said you you can get your account
back if you delete the joke the babylon
b duggan said we're not going to delete
the joke and then in comes eli and and
you know it's real you know that twitter
is freaking out right now because the
ceo of twitter prague agrawal
just sent out a big announcement he said
we're so excited to have elon musk on
board he's on the board of directors now
and we couldn't be happier please don't
fire me elon please and then elon
responds he says yes i we can't wait to
make some changes over at twitter
it's just
it's just delicious and the the best
part about it
is something that has that has bugged me
and i know it bugs a lot of other people
in the conservative movement which is
that
conservatives are pretty good at talking
and pretty good at writing and even
pretty good at raising money in
non-profit organizations
but we're we're less good at doing stuff
out in the actual marketplace out in the
actual political system
this is what jeremy talked about when he
launched the razer company jeremy came
out he said conservatives are really
good at whining and raising money and
then losing and then whining some more
and then raising some more money and
having a whole apparatus of non-profits
that doesn't really do very much
conservatives are good at that but if we
really believe that our ideas
are winners that they're vibrant that
they have strength we ought to throw
them right into the marketplace we ought
to actually try them out we ought to
throw our weight around we ought to we
ought to do more than just write
long journal articles i love journal
articles i read them i'm all about that
scholarly academic life it's great but
we have to do stuff in the real world
too and so elon rather than writing a
ten thousand word essay about the
importance of free speech he just threw
two billion dollars around and now he's
gonna do it
and we can we can debate the philosophy
of that a little bit later we can debate
the nuances of that a little bit but
he's gonna do it he's going to protect
free speech for now i strongly suspect
that's great stuff just do it learn from
nike take that nike rule conservatives
just do it and we'll figure it out you
want to make sure things are just and
moral and right and prudent but let's do
some stuff
and we'll let the chips fall a little
later we can do both
meanwhile
while we're winning on the business
front we've gotta we've got to do a
better job of winning on the political
front as well we are about to have a
supreme court justice of the united
states that is the farthest left justice
ever in the history of the court not
just of the justices right now though
she will be the furthest left justice
but ever in all of history this is a
woman who
praises the 1619 project which says
america's rotten and evil from the
beginning and it's based on a false
thesis that the american revolution was
fought to protect slavery
this is a woman who explicitly praises
the founders of critical race theory
notably derek bell
this is a woman
who lets
child rapists off the hook
this is because she takes the side of
criminals and she doesn't take the side
of victims this is this is a woman who
is real real radical
and according to the prominent libs
according to whoopi goldberg and the
ladies on the view
the real reason republicans oppose her
is because she's a black woman
you know what
let me shut up
lest i start some new stuff
you know this is the most reject just
say i don't trust a black woman to do
the job because i know
that y'all didn't have these same
issues
with amy coney barrett you didn't ask
those questions you didn't have those
problems and when amy coney barrett
answered the same way
that judge
kattani brown did when you asked her if
you thought they were going to
need more people on the supreme court
nobody seemed to have a problem with her
answer no but so many of you have
problems with with judgment you know
what i know what this is
yeah we all know what it is we know what
it is we recognize that we're used to
this but you know what you can't take
away what this woman is and who she is
and what she's done and
how whoopi knows
what we all know but especially whoopi
knows what this is about
this has nothing to do with katanji
jackson's radical record this has
nothing to do with kachanji jackson's
judicial philosophy which all
conservatives have opposed for decades
no
no no this has everything to do with her
race and her sex
tip but both together
it obviously doesn't have to do with her
race apart because
conservatives love clarence thomas he's
probably their favorite justice on the
court
and it it clearly doesn't have to do
with her sex because conservatives just
rallied and campaigned to get amy
barrett onto the court that was the last
judge we got on during the trump
administration
but
so republicans are fine with the black
people on the court and fine with women
on the court but but it's black black
women that's the problem that's what we
don't like i guess according to whoopi
goldberg
she is right i wouldn't trust just any
black woman on the court i would not
trust for instance whoopi goldberg on
the supreme court i don't trust katanji
jackson on the supreme court but it's
quite clear it's quite clear that the
opposition to katanji jackson has
nothing to do with race or sex as the
republicans have made very clear and as
is manifestly clear because of the
current judges that conservatives put on
the court but it's all the libs have got
and it's it's a lesson to conservatives
to the squishes
who are so they are more than anything
afraid of being called racist and to a
lesser degree sexist and so they will
just cave
all the time
you just saw this with mitt romney mitt
romney of course is voting to confirm
katanji jackson katanji jackson who has
judicial philosophy issues who has rec
issues on her record specifically issues
on letting child rapists off the hook
romney supports her and says oh yes
she'll she'll be fine she's great
i vote to support her nomination
mitt romney
will will not endorse mike lee his
fellow utah senator and a good
conservative
but he'll endorse catanji jackson
because mitt romney's job is to put
republicans in their place
that's his job his job is not to support
conservative policies
his job is not to promote a good
traditional free american way of life
his job
is to pretend to sort of kind of be a
republican and then put republicans in
their place
and insinuate that republicans are
bigots and racist and this is the natist
and he's one of the good ones he's one
of the good ones he's going to make that
stand what a maverick he is
but that's not it
no matter how hard the libs try
the katanji jackson confirmation process
is not primarily about race and sex her
nomination is about race and sex that's
what joe biden said he said i'm just
going to pick a black woman i'm going to
take a dart throw it at a dart board
full of black women and i'm just going
to pick one of them
that's all i care about
but the republican opposition is not
about that
because her nomination is not historic
the libs are always trying to make the
historic this is historic this moment in
history is so important finally a black
woman on the court politico said that
politico tweeted out yesterday this is a
very mainstream publication it's left
wing but it's very mainstream in dc
katanji brown jackson will likely be
confirmed as the first black supreme
court justice by the end of the week
here's how we expect it to go
the first black supreme court justice
not only is katanji jackson not the
first black supreme court justice she's
not the second black supreme court
justice
we've had black supreme court justices
for what half a century now
what about thurgood marshall this
thurgood marshall has totally been
erased it's not even as though we
previously had black supreme court
justices but we haven't had one for a
long time
we have one right now and he's pro he's
the most prominent member of the court
he's the senior most member of the court
and he's not even a liberal member of
the court he's a conservative member of
the court and he's probably the
conservatives favorite
this this article just completely wrong
politico then clarified it
and said for the record this replaces an
earlier tweet that stated that katanji
brown jackson could be the first black
supreme court justice it should have
said the first black female supreme
court justice we apologize for the error
and that this actually raised a question
to me is politico a biologist now
how does how does politico know that
katanji jackson is a woman
katanji jackson doesn't even know if
she's a woman and politico
is going to assume her gender and
furthermore politico is going to assume
the gender of thurgood marshall and
clarence thomas how do you know that
clarence thomas isn't a dainty woman
you don't know that politico how dare
you be so presumptuous so the the issues
with katanji's by the way
this is a slight point
i'm not going to refer to her as katanji
brown jackson
just like i'm not going to refer to amy
barrett as amy coney barrett just like
i'm not going to refer to ruth ginsburg
as ruth bader ginsburg
you get two names get over yourself you
get two names you get a first name and a
last name
your christian name and your family name
but you don't get three you're not i
don't like that it's if i don't it just
rubs me the wrong way
i don't it this might just be an
emotional reaction but i don't let's it
sounds pretentious to me katanji jackson
that's and and i if i were in the united
states senate right now i would not vote
for her not because of her race and sex
but because of her record we focused a
lot when we talk about judge jackson's
record on her extraordinarily low
sentencing record for child pornography
offenders and some people have come to
her defense on that they say look
yes obviously it's very very bad to look
at child pornography it's very very bad
to distribute child pornography it's an
abuse of children it's sexual abuse
images
but
in katanji's defense some of the
perpetrators they were young one of the
defenses that katanji made was that an
18 year old who was looking at a ton of
kitty porn of of kids who were eight
years old that they were peers
you know 8 18 what's the difference a
freshman in college and a third grader
what's the difference but okay there are
p there are actually some libertarians
on the right who say that uh child
pornography should not be prosecuted to
a great degree
that you know the images already exist
and then conservatives will come back
and say well actually if you look at the
images it's feeding the market and it
increases the abuse but okay
it's not just the cha it's not even just
the child porn that katanchi has a bad
record on
judge jackson
has apparently also got a very weak
sentencing record
on actual child
rapists
so katanji jackson
we've got the article right here it's in
the new york post
had a convicted child rapist come before
her court and he was in violation of
of some of his sentencing previously for
this child rape this is a guy who raped
his 13 year old cousin i believe it was
cousin or niece or something like that
the prosecutor in that case ari redboard
said
this is not a butt grab a misdemeanor
kind of case this is not consensual sex
between a 20 year old and a 16 year old
this is an individual who at trial was
convicted of essentially violently
raping a 13 year old child so we're
talking about a bad dude
and
judge jackson sentenced him for
violating the conditions of his
sentencing his previous sentencing for
the rape
to 12 months with credit for time served
according to the transcript much much
lower than the guidelines would suggest
much much lower than the prosecutor was
asking for
this is not this is no longer even just
an 18 year old who fell down a bad
rabbit hole on the internet we're
talking about a guy who's really done
this
in real physical life
again is this because katanji jackson is
a pedophile i don't think so is this
because katanji jackson
has some strange sexual hang up with
kids i don't think so
the left the left broadly does seem to
have a weird sexual hang up with kids
these days as we see with with the
left wing in florida right now and the
reaction to the parental rights and
education bill but what i think this is
about is is something even frankly even
more disturbing this is about a radical
political ideology that will always
100 percent take the side of the
criminals and the perpetrators to the
complete neglect of the victims this is
a complete disordering of justice in
america
and the woman who's pushing it is going
to be the next supreme court justice in
the united states and she's going to do
so with the guffaws and the seal
collapse and the applause of the
squishes like mitt romney
absolutely pathetic
the
child rape
sentencing is is not the end of the
radicalism that we've seen from katanji
jackson yes she's weak on kitty porn yes
she's weak on actual child rape
she also
just within the last couple of years
tried to empty out the jails in dc tried
to just completely empty them out
and as her excuse she used kovid
katanji jackson said that in the early
days of the pandemic it would be
reasonable quote reasonable to release
each and every person in washington dc
jails
and then she went on to grant covid
related releases
to defendants and inmates who were
implicated in very serious crimes
now the problem with this too just to
put a little button on the child rapist
story
is
when katanji jackson
let this child rapist off the hook with
a much lighter sentence than people were
asking for what do you think he did do
you think he went out and became an
upstanding member of society and turned
his life around no he assaulted another
woman he went out and he assaulted his
sister-in-law he sexually assaulted her
tried to rape her she initially was
bringing charges then she didn't
the woman ended up
wanting to pass on that because it
apparently was very painful for her
family but the guy went out and offended
again
while he should have been in jail if
katanji jackson hadn't let him off the
hook
then she wanted to bring that same
philosophy to every
inmate in washington dc
and we're not talking about people who
got got thrown in the clink for parking
tickets we're talking about pretty
serious crimes here
she said quote
the obvious increased risk of harm that
the kovid 19 pandemic poses two
individuals who have been detained in
the district's correctional facilities
reasonably suggests that each and every
criminal defendant who's currently in dc
doc custody and who thus cannot take
independent measures to control their
own hygiene and distance themselves from
others should be released
each
and
every
we've never seen anything like that
we're also coincidentally experiencing a
major crime spike throughout the country
violent crime murders shootings rapes
way up through the roof all over the
place and and they're way up
not because of some random turn of the
weather and the wheel of fortune but
because of specific democrat policies
notably letting the criminals out of
prison some republicans have supported
this too they've supported jailbreak
bills as well but it's being led by
democrats who want to abolish the police
who want to defund the police who want
to abolish prisons prominent d.c members
of the house of representatives
democrats in congress are calling to
abolish federal prisons rashida talib
the george harrison of the squad is
calling to abolish abolish just totally
get rid of federal prisons within 10
years
and there are others who are supporting
her in that effort
well what's the consequence turns out
when you let the criminals out of prison
things don't get better what the left
believes is that the criminals are only
in prison
they only commit crimes because society
made them do it society failed them
they didn't get enough hugs and so now
they're committing all these crimes and
if you just let them out and you give
them a stern talking to
if that then they're going to stop
committing crimes
and they don't they commit more crimes
and our country falls to
ash and it gets worse and worse and
worse until finally people have enough
and they vote in republicans who throw
the criminals in prison and then we get
a period of some good years
you see this cycle play out in new york
yet
crime and mayhem and destruction and a
terrible experience
70s 1980s then you get a giuliani
giuliani cleans it up throws the
prisoners in the clink this isn't brain
surgery this isn't rocket science and
then things get much better and
bloomberg kind of maintains that and
then the libs get some power back again
people get sick of all that peace and
prosperity they let the criminals out
and you rinse and repeat you do the same
cycle
right now in chicago
crime is through the roof the place is
like a failed middle eastern state
turns out 57 of chicagoans who are
arrested for carjacking are miners
50
more than half the carjackings in
chicago are being committed by teenagers
or children that's how messed up that
city is and when asked to explain what's
going on the mayor of chicago lori
lightfoot says
it's just because the children don't
feel
loved
there are too many young people in this
room who do not feel loved
too many
and we've got to change that around if
we're going to change around the
trajectory of their lives
the mayor says we cannot arrest
ourselves out of public safety problems
we cannot we cannot arrest ourselves out
of crime
i think we can
i i'm pretty sure
not
in politics lots of issues are kind of
confusing and nuanced but this issue is
pretty straightforward
if you arrest the criminals you don't
get crime
that's how you that's that is the only
way to fix it actually
well but what about the children who
don't feel loved you're right she's
actually right on that point
part of the reason that
kids go into crime part of it is that
it's a fallen world and it's an
imperfect world and you're never on this
earth going to perfect human nature
but you can make it better and you can
make it worse and part of the reason
that you're seeing an increase in crime
is because kids are not loved
so fix that
you know
you know what's not going to fix that
encouraging the dissolution of families
uh encouraging
single motherhood destroying the very
definition of the family
sending kids to failing schools where
they're not going to get an education
discouraging the teaching of ethics and
morality in schools which is now all but
against the law
teaching actual morality actual ethics
in schools that's not permitted the one
book you're not allowed to teach in
school is the bible you're allowed to
teach any craziness you want you can
teach ibram candy you can teach critical
race theory transgenderism you can teach
mind comp for goodness sakes you can't
teach the bible
that would seem to be a problem
uh we kill 800 000 babies a year that
doesn't make children feel very loved
lori lightfoot supports all that crap
so that's
i'm not even denying her premise
entirely
look you got to arrest the people
committing the crimes that's an act of
love to them if you allow
criminals
derelicts bums to just live on the
street and commit crimes that's not an
act of love that's an act of neglect
that's not helping them at all it's
they're going to
further harm themselves body and soul
they're going to further harm society
they're going to further mess up their
lives it's an act of love to correct
them we call it the correctional
facilities it's an act of love to
correct them for the society and for
them as well
and then when we're talking about how to
form kids into not committing
carjackings in chicago
whatever whatever they're doing in
chicago right now whatever the democrat
politicians are doing there obviously
it's not working
maybe we ought to try the opposite maybe
instead of talking to five-year-olds
about how they should chop off their
body parts and take cross-sex hormones
maybe we ought to teach them well one
reading writing and arithmetic so they
can become productive accomplished
members of society and pursue excellence
and maybe we ought to teach them basic
ethics and morality the difference
between true and false and right and
wrong and good and evil can you imagine
can you imagine if they would do that in
chicago
can you it's actually hard to imagine
right now so far gone is that city so
far gone is the left maybe they ought to
take rather than condemning places like
florida and more conservative states
maybe they ought to take notes i'm
michael nolis the michael knowles shall
see tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary supervising producer mathis glover
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022. on the matte wall show
we talk about the things that matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show